हेलो गाइज वेलकम टू आवर
youtube1 मेरा नाम है आयुष पाठक और आज हम
लोग क्या करने वाले हैं नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी का डे 11 ओके तो आपको ऑलरेडी
पता है कि डेट 10 तक जो है नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी की सीरीज आ चुकी है यह सीरीज
काफी धीरे-धीरे चल रही है आराम से चल रही
है ताकि आप लोग बाकी सीरीज के साथ-साथ
इसको पढ़ते रहे जैसे कि आपको ऑलरेडी पता
है कि अगर आप हमारे
youtube2 की सीरीज मिलेगी जिसके ऑलरेडी
नाइन लेक्चर हो चुके हैं जो लाइव चलती है
इसके साथ-साथ आप कर सक इसलिए लेक्चर जो है
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी के वो धीरे-धीरे आ रहे
हैं ठीक है लास्ट लेक्चर में मैंने आपको
कुछ रिवीजन करवाया था ठीक है इस लेक्चर
में उसके आगे बढ़ने वाले हैं तो इससे पहले
मैं बता दूं आपको कि आप लिन पे हमारे पेज
को सर्च करके फॉलो कर सकते हैं और
नेटवर्क सर्विसेस वाला ये आप आप ट्रायक प
सर्च करेंगे नेटवर्क सर्विसेस उसके आपको
दो रूम मिलेंगे एक नेटवर्क सर्विसेस और एक
नेटवर्क सर्विसेस टू तो हम लोग पहले यहां
पर हमने यहां तक कर ही लिया है इसके बाद
हम नेटवर्क सर्विसेस और नेटवर्क सर्विसेस
टू करेंगे ठीक है जिसमें हम इन जो
प्रोटोकॉल्स हमने पहले पढ़े उनके अलावा
कुछ और प्रोटोकॉल्स का और उनका
एक्सप्लोरेशन है इसके बाद फिर हम वापस से
कंटिन्यू कर रहे होंगे इसी मॉड्यूल पे ठीक
है फिर हम लोग प्रोटोकॉल एंड सर्वर टू
करेंगे फिर एक चैलेंज देखेंगे और फिर
एक्स्ट्रा जो भी चीजें होंगी उसके हिसाब
से हम देखेंगे आगे आपके डिमांड के ऊपर
रहेगा कि ये सीरीज कितनी लंबी होने वाली
है लेकिन फिलहाल यहां तक तो होने ही वाला
ठीक है चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं अभी अटैक
बॉक्स य चालू कर देता हूं पहले हीता य पर
जरूरत पड़
जाए ये स्टार्ट हो रहा है हम आगे बढ़ते
हैं अब यहां पर इस रूम में क्या होने वाला
है इस रूम कार मैं आपको एक ओवरव्यू दूं तो
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पर क्या है यहां पर
बेसिकली एसएमबी टेलनेट और एटीपी के बारे
में समझने वाले हैं और उसका एक्सप्लोरेशन
भी देखने वाले हैं ठीक है
चलिए य पर स्टार्ट करते हैं इसको पहले ओके
कर देते हैं य कंप्लीट है अब
अंडरस्टैंडिंग एसएमबी एक बार रिकॉल कीजिए
कि आपको एसएमबी के बारे में कुछ कुछ पता
है क्या मैंने बताया था अभी तक एक बार
सोचिए उसको आंसर सोचिए फिर मैं बता रहा
हूं आगे ठीक है चलिए एसएमबी क्या है
एसएमबी है सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक प्रोटोकॉल ये
एसएमबी का फुल फॉर्म हो गया ठीक है इससे
क्या क्या ही फर्क पड़ता है ये क्लाइंट
सर्वर कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है अब
क्लाइंट सर्वर कम्युनिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल का
मतलब क्या हुआ मतलब जैसे ये जो डायग्राम
बना हुआ है उससे समझ सकते हैं कि एक तरफ
से रिक्वेस्ट भेजी जा रही है और एक तरफ से
रिस्पांस आ रहा है ठीक है एक तरफ से नहीं
मत दोनों तरफ से ये चीज हो रही है ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पर इसका यूज़ क्यों होता है
इसका यूज होता है अपने रिसोर्सेस को शेयर
करने के लिए ठीक है अपने फाइल सिस्टम उसके
ठीक है जैसे प्रिंटर हो गया या फिर बाकी
फाइल्स हो गई फोल्डर हो गया वो चीजें जैसे
कि यहां पे लिखा हुआ है क्लाइंट
कंप्यूटर्स यानी जो कनेक्ट कर रहा है किसी
एसएमबी सर्वर से ठीक है क्लाइंट
कंप्यूटर्स मे हैव देयर ओन हार्ड डिस्क बट
दे आल्सो वांट एक्सेस टू द शेयर्ड फाइल
सिस्टम कहने का मतलब क्या या फिर
प्रिंटर्स ऑन द सर्वर कहने का मतलब हमारा
एक एसएमबी सर्वर सेटअप है ठीक है उसमें
काफी सारी फाइल रखी है और हमारे कई सारे
कंप्यूटर आपस में कनेक्टेड हैं तो हमारा
जो सर्वर है अगर उसमें एसएमबी इनेबल्ड है
उसमें कोई फोल्डर या कोई हार्ड डिस्क अगर
शेयर हो रही है जितने लोग उससे कनेक्टेड
हैं विद सम ऑथेंटिकेशन या विदाउट
ऑथेंटिकेशन जैसे भी हमने सेलेक्ट किया
होगा उसके बेस पे उन सारे फाइल या
फोल्डर्स को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं ठीक है
इसलिए हम एमबी का इस्तेमाल करते हैं चलिए
आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां पर लिखा है एसबी कैसे
चलता है तो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विज 95 के बाद से
यह विंडोज में तो आता ही है ठीक है अगर
आपको इसका इंप्लीमेंटेशन में देखना है तो
उसको आप सबा नाम से जान सकते हैं सेबा इज
एन ओपन सोर्स सर्वर दैट सपोर्ट्स द एसएमबी
प्रोटोकॉल एंड वास रिलीजड फॉर य सिस्टम य
वही हुआ ठीक है चलिए तो एमबी का फुल फॉर्म
क्या हुआ सोचिए रिकॉल कीजिए मन
में
य हो गया व्ट टाइप ऑ प्रोटोकॉल ी कि
प्रोटोल अभी बताया य क्लाइंट सर्वर
प्रोटोकॉल है ठीक है य रिक्वेस्ट रिपस भी
ले सकता है कोई बड़ी बात नहीं है
इसम देखते हैं य किस तरीके से इसको आंसर
चाहिए सर्वर
कम्युनिकेशन ट्र का य रता ड़ कि आपको इनके
सिंटेक्स में आंसर देना है तो वो भी एक
बात है य पर हुआ तो ऐसे कुछ क्लाइंट सर्वर
टाइप देख लेते बार अच्छे से यहां पर
रिक्वेस्ट ओ रिस्पांस रिक्वेस्ट प्रोटोकॉल
हो सकता है इसका
आंसर होप फुली यही होने वाला है आंसर इसको
हटा देते हैं हा सही है रिस्पांस
रिक्वेस्ट बेस्ड ठीक है चलिए व्हाट डू
क्लाइंट्स कनेक्ट टू सर्वर्स यूजिंग व्हाट
डू क्लाइंट्स कनेक्ट टू सर्वर्स यूजिंग
क्या मतलब क्या व्हाट डू क्लाइंट्स कनेक्ट
टू सर्वर्स यूजिंग इसका कुछ मतलब नहीं है
ठीक है सर्वर्स यूजिंग ए ब और
क्या ओके ओ ओके ओके टीसीपी आईपी ओके ओके
इसका आंसर होने वाला है टीसीपी
आईपी इसका मतलब ये है कि क्लाइंट जो
कनेक्ट करते हैं वो क्या यूज करके कनेक्ट
करते हैं ठीक है तो ओबवियस बात है एमबी जब
क्योंकि फाइल शेयरिंग के लिए काम आ रहा है
मैंने आपको जब टीसीपी और यूडीपी पढ़ाया तो
मैंने आपको समझाया था टीसीपी क्या होता है
टीसीपी रिलायबल कनेक्शन होता है क्यों
क्योंकि टीसीबी इस चीज का पूरा ध्यान रखता
है कि जो भी डाटा भेजा गया है वो कंपलीटली
रिसीव हुआ है कि नहीं और हर चीज का ध्यान
रखता है लेकिन यूडीपी क्या करता है भेज
दिया डाटा मिले चाहे मत मिले कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ता ठीक है तो अगर हम यहां पर
एसएमबी में फाइल शेयरिंग और इस टाइप का
काम है तो ओबवियस है कि हम क्या यूज़
करेंगे टीपी टीसीपी ठीक है चलिए व्हाट
सिस्टम्स डस s रन ऑन य या
से ठीक है स्टार्ट कर देते हैं इसको भी
टैग बॉक्स हमारा चालू हो चुका होगा इसको
न्यू टैब में ओपन कर लेते हैं चलिए टैग
बॉक्स भी हमारा चालू हो गया है टर्मिनल
ओपन कर लेते
हैं एक बात मैं बोल देता हूं आपको अच्छे
से कि मेरा ये जो भी वीडियोस आप लेक्चर
देख रहे हैं वो तो ठीक है इसके बाद आपको
ये सब चीज खुद से भी ट्राई करनी चाहिए और
जहां मैं कहता हूं या जहां मैं नहीं भी कह
रहा हूं वहां आपको पॉज करके एक बार मुझसे
एक कदम आगे सोचने की कोशिश करनी चाहिए कि
पहले क्या क्या इसमें हो सकता है फिर
वीडियो प्ले करिए इससे आपके क्या बेनिफिट
है इससे मेरा तो कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है जो
है आप ही का है ठीक है तो अगर आपको
नेटवर्क पेंट्रेशन टेस्टिंग में या इन सब
चीजों में इंटरेस्ट है तो आपको ये चीज
काफी ज्यादा काम आने वाली है क्योंकि
इसमें हैंड्स ऑन एक्सपीरियंस की काफी
जरूरत है इसमें क्या इन जनरल साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में हैंड्स ऑन एक्सपीरियंस तो
काफी जरूरी होता ही है आप सिर्फ वीडियो
देख के तो नहीं कर सकते काम सोचना भी है
खुद से आपको ट्राई भी करना है खुद से ठीक
है ठीक है कमांड्स आपको याद नहीं रहे
उसमें कोई दिक्कत नहीं है पर आपको चीजें
पता होनी चाहिए
ओवरऑल चलिए शुरू करते हैं तो यहां पर बात
करते हैं एनिलेशन की ठीक है ये तो लिया
हुआ है कि इवेशन क्या होता है वो मैंने
आपको ऑलरेडी बता दिया है उसके बारे में
बताने की को जरूरत नहीं है किसी चीज को
लेक उसके अंदर डीप घुसना उसके बारे में
समझना अच्छे से और उसके जो भी अटैक
सर्फेसेज है और जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन है उसको
गैदर करना आ गया न्यूमरेशन में चलिए अब
यहां पर दिया हुआ है कि देर आर एबी शर ठीक
है मैंने आपको बताया कि एबी शेयर्स होते
हैं यानी जो भी फोल्डर है या प्रिंटर है
जो भी चीजें है ठीक है वो शेयर के रूप में
है ठीक है ना चलिए अब यहां पर क्या लिया
हु है पहले पोर्ट स्कैनिंग से स्टार्ट
करना है ठीक है तो ये रूम में हमने पढ़
लिया ऑलरेडी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग को हमने एकदम
डिटेल में देख लिया जितने मेथड होते हैं
उससे पहले क्या किया जाता है कि लाइव
होस्ट को डिटेक्ट कर सक उसके बाद क्या
किया जाता है ठीक है यानी ओएस डिटेक्शन
बैर ग्रबिंग ये सब हमने पढ़ लिया है ठीक
है तो इससे हमें कोई मतलब नहीं है अब यहां
पर एक ये टूल के बारे में बताया है ए फॉर
है और कोई हो सकता है मलवे एनालिसिस कर
रहा हो कोई कुछ और कर रहा हो ठीक है जो
जिस सेक्टर में बढ़ता है साइबर सिक्योरिटी
में भी क्योंकि बहुत सारी फील्ड है जो जिस
सेक्टर में बढ़ता है उसको उस सेक्टर के
टूल्स एंड टेक्निक्स सब कुछ धीरे-धीरे याद
होने लगते हैं ठीक है जो जनरली यूज होते
हैं हमेशा बाकी न्यू इवोल्यूशन तो होता
रहता है हमेशा तो उसमें ये नहीं है कि
आपको सब कुछ याद हो जाएगा एक बार में कभी
नहीं हो सकता ठीक है ना तो वही बात है
चलिए आगे बढ़ते हैं यहां पर यहां पर टूल्स
के कुछ ऑप्शन दिया है जैसे हाई फन यू यूजर
लिस्ट पाने के लिए हान m मशीन लिस्ट पाने
के लिए हान ए नेम लिस्ट डम के लिए और ऐसे
यहां बहुत सारे फीचर दिए हुए हैं इसके
बारे में हम धीरे-धीरे समझेंगे ठीक है
इसका सिंटेक्स क्या है देखिए एनय फॉर
ठीक है हमें इस आईपी एड्रेस पे एक पहले
एनवे स्कैन करना पड़ेगा हम क्या करते
हैं एक बेसिक सा एनम स्कैन करते हैं लेकिन
हम सारे पोट डिफाइन कर देते हैं क्योंकि
इसमें ये नहीं लिखा कि आपको सिर्फ टॉप
1000 पोट करने हैं तो हम सारे पोट स्कैन
कर लेते हैं वर्स कर देते हैं आउटपुट को
और हमने हान ए स्विच नहीं लगाया है
क्योंकि हमें डिटेल में जाने की कोई जरूरत
नहीं है कि क्या उसमें अभी है ठीक है अभी
के लिए फिलहाल हम देखते हैं मेरे खल से
तीन यहां पर आ चुका है देखते हैं अगर तीन
से काम चल जाते तो स्टॉप कर देंगे स्कैन
को अपने ओके ठीक है तो ये तीन बेसिकली दो
तो इसमें एमबी के ही है अब हमें कर
सकते प की जगह हम पोर्ट को स् कर देंगे कि
हम पोर्ट 139 ठीक है पोर्ट 445 और पोट 2
को स्कैन करना है
और हम हान ए भी दे देते हैं चलिए अभ देखि
य जो पोर्ट है य एबी वाला है ठीक है
बताएगा 2 को छोड़ के बाकी दोनों
पटने लगाया है तो व अपने आप स्क्र दिखाएगा
सर्च करके मतलब स्क्रि होती है जो भी टे
होती है व सारी अपलाई होंगी रेशन के लिए
वेट करते हैं आ देखते क्या है व्ट पोर्ट
रनिंग ऑन ठीक है एबी कौन से पोर्ट रन हो
रहा है कौन सा पोर्ट हुआ
आपका की बेसिक इमेशन आ गई है कैसे आई व
समझेंगे मैनली अभी ठीक है तो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है उस कौन सा आया है और 445 य ल्ट पट
होते हैं ठीक है 139 एंड
445 चलिए हो गया यह तो क्या हो गया ए स्कन
करेंगे आप देखेंगे 45 तो प्र य एी होगा
ठीक है दे सते य पर हो रहा य पर सेम बाय
सेम बीडी 4.7 प समथिंग ठीक है वर्जन है ये
उसका अब यहां पर उसके आगे स्क्रिप्ट चली
है इसको देख लेते हैं कुछ यहां पर शेयर्स
और बाकी कुछ चीजों के नाम है वर्क ग्रुप्स
के ओ का नाम यहां पर आ गया विंडो 6.1 ठीक
है ये ए की डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट्स है चलिए
आगे देखते हैं क्वेश्चन क्या है उसके से
बढ़ते हैं आगे लेट्स गेट स्टार्टेड विद
एनम फॉर नक्स कंडक्ट अ फुल बेसिक एमेशन
फॉर स्टार्टर्स व्हाट इज द वर्क ग्रुप नेक
ठीक है हमें क्या करना है फुल बेसिक एमेशन
अब इसके हेल्प पे आइए ठीक है याद करने की
जरूरत नहीं है ये देखिए फुल बेसिक एमेशन
मतलब सब कुछ एमेट कर दो जितना कर सकते हो
क्या लगाना है
ठीक है य हमारे लिएने कर दिया है पर हम इस
रिजल्ट को हटा देंगे अभी हम करने वाले हैं
से
ही देंगे हम और अपने आई एड्रेस को पेस्ट
कर देंगे सॉरी हो इस आईपी एड्रेस को हम य
पर क्या करने वाले है पेस्ट करने वाले हैं
चलिए इसको रन करता हूं देखता हूं कितनी
इमेशन निकाल सकता है हमारे लिए य क्वेन
क्या पूछे गए पला क्वे ट वर्ग ग्रुप नेम
वर्ग ग्रुप का नेम क्या है य पर का नेम
देख लेते
हैं ओके वर्क ग्रुप का नेम य पर क्या है
पोलो एसबी ठीक है ल देते
हैं ओ सॉरी सॉरी वर्ग ग्रुप का नाम यहां
पर वर्ग ग्रुप ही है ठीक है वर्ग ग्रुप का
नाम तो वर्ग ग्रुप ही है मास्टर का नाम है
यहां पर पोलोस भी ठीक है चलिए नाम तो वर्ग
ग्रुप ही
है सही हो गया व्ट कम्स अप एस द नेम ऑफ द
मशीन मशीन का नाम हमारा क्या आ रहा है
मशीन का नाम मेरे ख्याल से ये होने वाला
है पोलो एसएमबी ठीक है इसको खते हैं पोलो
एसएमबी सही है वट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम व रनिंग
कौन सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम रन हो रहा है तो ए
से हमने ऑलरेडी देख लिया था वि 6.1 है
स्टिल हम देखते हैं कि ए फ उसको डिटेक्ट
कर पाया है कि नहीं कर पाया ओके ओ वर्जन
6.1 ठीक है चलिए देखते यहां
पर 6.1
चलिए हो गया व्हाट शेयर स्टिक्स आउट
समथिंग वी माइट वांट टू इन्वेस्टिगेट अब
देखिए इसके आउटपुट को एनालाइज करते हैं
यहां से हमारा शुरू हो रहा था यहां पे
टारगेट बेसिक इंफॉर्मेशन है ठीक है यहां
पर पहले वर्क ग्रुप का एमेशन शुरू हुआ है
य परने व डिस्कवर किया है फिर य पर इसने
ट्राई किया है एमटी से बता इसके बारे में
आगे भी ठीक है पर इमेशन निकाली गई
है य पर आपको शेयर के रेशन मिलेंगे ठीक
हैय सब आपके इंफॉर्मेशन है और यहां पर य
उनको कनेक्ट करने की ट्राई किया ठीक और
आपको य लोकल ग्रुप य को डिक करने की कोशिश
करता
हैरा य पूरा जो है उसका आउटपुट लग तो हम
आते शेयर वाले पार्ट में शेयर्स वाला
पार्ट हमारा ये र ठीक है देखते हैं क्या
क्वेश्चन पूछा गया था व्ट शेयर स्टेक्स
आउट समथिंग वी माइट वांट टू इन्वेस्टिगेट
ठीक है इनमें से क्या ऐसा लग रहा है जो
हमें इन्वेस्टिगेट करना अच्छा लग सकता है
तो मेरे ख्याल से यहां पर प्रोफाइल्स लग
रहा है यूजर प्रोफाइल्स यहां कुछ डिटेल्स
मिल सकती है ट्राई करते हैं प्रोफाइल्स
को ओके सही है चलिए तो आपने क्या किया
सबसे पहले हमने क्या किया एप से स्कैनिंग
किया स्कैन का काम चला कि ठीक है भाई एमबी
पोर्ट जो है वो ओपन है ठीक है अब एमबी
पोर्ट चकि ओपन है एमबी पोर्ट ओपन होने के
बाद हमने क्या किया उसम डिस्कवरी चालू की
किससे चालू की एम फर l से हमने लगाया ए फर
ट करने का दो तीन तरीका हो सकता है जैसे
कि यहां भी लिखा हुआ है कि कुछ नॉन
वल्नरेबल होती है जैसे ये वाला है इसको
ओपन करते हैं मेरे ख्याल से ये शायद वही
वाली है ओके चलिए ठीक है देखिए जैसे यहां
पर ये रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन व बिलिटी है
ठीक है कौन से वर्जन में सबा सिंस वर्जन
3.50 एंड बिफोर इतना इतने से इतने वर्जन
के बीच में है तो एक तो ये आपका
डायरेक्टली मतलब सीवी बेज अटैक हो गया ठीक
है कि अगर आपका सबा ही वल्नरेबल है रिमोट
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन या ऐसी किसी वल्नरेबल है
तो आप सीधे अटैक कर सकते हैं चाहे उस
वर्जन में कितनी भी सिक्योरिटी सही से
लगाई गई हो अगर अगर वर्जन नहीं ब तो तो
डैक हो ही जाएगा ठीक है कंफीग्रशन कितना
भी सही हो तो एक तो वो तरीका है लेकिन अभी
हम वो लोग तरीके की बात नहीं करने वाले
हैं हम बात करने वाले मिस कन्फेशन तरीके
की क्योंकि उसमें क्या ही है आपको आता ही
होगा अगर नहीं आता तो मैं आपको आगे
दिखाऊंगा ऐसे हम सीटीएस करेंगे वो वही चीज
है उसमें कुछ नया नहीं है आपको सर्च करना
है सिंपल एक्सप्लोइट्स अप्लाई कर देना है
मेटा स्पॉड से या किसी भी चीज से ठीक है
अभी हम बात करने वाले हैं मिस कंफीग्रशन
की मिस कंफीग्रशन में क्या होता है देखिए
हमने नरेशन से क्या पाया हमने पाया एसएमबी
के शेयर लोकेशन और नेम ऑफ इंटरेस्टिंग
एसएमबी शेयर हमें एक जो इंटरेस्टिंग लगा
उसके बारे में अब एसएमबी क्लांट एक टूल है
जो मेरे ख्याल से इसमें पहले से आता होगा
इसको भी टेस्ट कर लेता हूं मैं एसएमबी
क्लाइंट आता है ठीक है एसएमबी क्लाइंट ये
एक टूल है जो हमें एसएमबी से कम्युनिकेट
करने शेयर्स को व्यू करने ठीक है और इन
सबके काम आता है ठीक है तो अब कहेंगे इससे
क्या मतलब है भाई मैंने आपको क्या कहा था
उस टाइम के एसबी का इस्तेमाल आप कर सकते
हैं जैसे कोई सर्वर है कोई सिस्टम है एसबी
सर्वर है उसपे इंपोर्टेंट फाइल्स है जितने
भी यूजर आपके नेटवर्क के सब लोग एबी सर्वर
को एक्सेस कर रहे हैं विथ ऑथेंटिकेशन और
विदाउट ऑथेंटिकेशन ये मैंने आपसे कहा था
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि आपने अपने सर्वर
को जैसा भी कन्फर कर रखा है कि यूजर नेम
पासवर्ड मांगो या ना मांगो उस बेस प वो
काम कर रहा है जैसे एफटीपी में होता है
एनोनिमस लॉगिन उस टाइप का तो अब क्या करने
वाले हैं देखिए ये एसएमबी क्लाइंट की
कमांड है कनेक्ट करने के लिए अब एमबी
क्लांट यहां पर डबल स्लैश ठीक है फॉरवर्ड
स्लैश मशीन का आईपी एड्रेस स्लश फर शेयर
का नेम देंगे तो आप उस शेयर से कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं और आप हान य लगा के अपना यूजर
नेम भी स्पेसिफाई कर सकते हैं आपको य ये
यूजर नेम है ठीक है और आन पीछ आप पोर्ट दे
सकते हैं अगर पोर्ट डिफॉल्ट नहीं है तो
ठीक है तो हम क्या करने वाले हैं हम ट्राई
करने वाले बिना किसी इमेशन के देखिए पहले
य पर करते क्या लिखा हुआ है व्ट वड बी द
करेक्ट सिंटेक्स टू एक्सेस एसबी शेयर
कॉल्ड सिगरेट हमें क्या करना है एसबी शेयर
एक्सेस करना सबसे पहले काम तो एमबी
क्लाइंट टूल को इवोक करो ठीक है इसके बाद
क्या लिखा है कॉ हमारी मशीन की आईपी क्या
है 10 102 10 10 10 ठीक है इस आईपी प कौन
सा शेयर हम एक्सेस करना है शेर का नाम
सीक्रेट ठीक है और यूजर हमारा क्या होने
वाला है ने वाला है सूट ठीक है ये आपका वो
हो गया न डिफॉल्ट पोट लिखा लिए पोट स्फाई
नहीं किया ये कमांड का सिंटेक्स है ठीक है
चलिए अब यहां पर लिखा हुआ है कि हम यहां
पर काम करने वाले हैं यू हैव अ लिस्ट ऑफ
यूजर्स द नेम ऑफ शेयर एमबी एंड सप
लेबिलिटी लेट्स सी इफ इंटरेस्टिंग शेयर
कंफ टू अलाउ एनोनिमस एक्सेस ठीक है
एनोनिमस एक्सेस की बात हो गई जैसे मैंने
आपको कहा था उस टाइम से एफटीपी में होता
है वही चीज यहां पर होने वाली है ठीक है
मिस कॉन्फिन की वह से चीजें होती है हम
क्या करने वाले हैं यूजर नेम एनोनिमस देने
वाले हैं ठीक है अब हम कनेक्ट करेंगे अपने
शेयर पे ठीक है बिना पासवर्ड दिए देखते
हैं कि हमारा शेयर जो है व कनेक्ट हो रहा
है कि नहीं हो रहा है तो हम क्या करेंगे
एसएमबी क्लाइंट हमने दिया ठीक है आईपी
एड्रेस हम यहां पर कॉपी करके पेस्ट कर
देते
हैं आई एड्रेस हमारा पेस्ट हो गया हमारा
प्रोफाइल नाम था मेरे ख्याल से शेयर का
ठीक है हान यूजर करते हैं यूजर हमारा बने
वाला है
एनोनिमस ठीक है अब एंटर करते हैं देखते य
पासवर्ड मांगता है कि नहीं पासवर्ड मांग
रहा है हम एंटर कर देंगे सिंपली कुछ
पासवर्ड नहीं डालेंगे देखते यहां पर
कनेक्ट हो
गया ये देखिए यहां पर कनेक्ट हो चुका है
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे सामने आ गई है जो भी
शेयर के अंदर जो फाइल शेयर की गई है वो
मेरे आ गई ठीक इसका मतलब हमें एक्सेस मिल
गया कौन से कहां प एक्सेस मिला सिस्टम
एक्सेस नहीं मिला हम ठीक है हमें सिर्फ
शेयर सॉरी प्रोफाइल नाम का जो शेयर था उसम
एक्सेस मिला है ठीक है डस शेयर अला अमस
एक्सेस यस तभी हम कनेक्ट कर पाए ग्रेट हैव
अ लुक अराउंड फॉर एनी इंटरेस्टिंग
डॉक्यूमेंट कुड कंटेन लबल इंफॉर्मेशन हु
कैन वी अजूम दिस प्रोफाइल फोल्डर बिलोंग
टू ओके हमें यहां पर कुछ सस फशन देखनी है
वर्किंग फ्रॉम होम इंफॉर्मेशन ठीक है इसको
हम देखते हैं वर्किंग फ्रॉम
हो गई क्या ओके ठीक है हम य पर डबल कोड
देना पड़ सकता है हम फाइल डाउनलोड करने
वाले अपने सिस्टम प ठीक है चलिए य फ
ाउनलोड हो गई है और देखते कौन सी फाइल
पोर्टेंट लग रही है य पर डट प्रोफाइल सय
ठीक हैफो बच ल देखते हैं क्या
है ओके ठीक है ये डायरेक्टरी है इसम अंदर
जाते है देखते य पर क्या है हमारे पास ठीक
है तो आईडी आर एसए आईडी आरएस के बारे में
पता होगा ये एच की की होती है जिसकी वजह
से आप एसस कर सकते हैं अपने सिस्टम में
ठीक है ये पब्लिक की है तो ये तो चलेगा
पब्लिक की तो चल सकती है ठीक है प्राइवेट
की ये वाली है अगर प्राइवेट की आपको मिल
जाती है तो आप कर सकते हैं उससे काम अपना
ठीक है देखते सीडीरा की में क्या रखा हुआ
है ओके डक्टरी नहीं है ये भी गेट कर लेते
हैं इसको भी आईडी अ आर एसए को ठीक है इसको
भी गेट कर लेते हैं चलिए अब एजट कर देते
अपने एमबी से अ सिस्टम प आ गया हूं मैं
एलस करता हूं वापस से मेरे सामने देखिए
वर्किंग फ्रॉम होम इंफॉर्मेशन आ गया है
मैं कैट करता हूं इसको इस फाइल को
देख लेते फाइल को
ओके जॉन कैक्टस एस यू आर वेल अवेयर ड्यू
टू द करेंट पम जो भी चीज लिख र मुझे उससे
मतलब ही नहीं है इपोर्ट चीज य कि जॉन
कैक्टस नाम मिल गया हमारा क्वेश्चन क्या
था यहां पर य प्रोफाइल किसकी लग रही है
आपको य प्रोफाइल है जॉन कैक्टस की भाई नाम
तो बहुत बढ़िया है य कॉपी कर लेते हैं
इसका य पेस्ट करते हैं ठीक है चलिए य भी
हो गया वट सर्विस हैविंग फिगर टू अलाउ हिम
टू वर्क फ्रॉम होम कौन सी सर्विस अलाउ कर
रही है उसको वर्क फ्रॉम अकाउंट एस ठीक है
एसस की वजह से वो वर्क फ्रॉम होम कर पा
रहा है देख रहे हैं एच का फायदा चलिए ओके
नाउ वी नो दिस व्हाट डायरेक्टरी ऑफ द शेयर
शुड वी लुक इन अब हमें कौन सी डायरेक्टरी
में देखना है हमें देखना है डॉट एस के
अंदर ये तो ओबवियस बात है और ये देख के भी
समझ में रहा है क् देखिए इसके आंसर
सिंटेक्स में क्या दिया हुआ है डॉट फ
स्टार स्ट स्टाइल इसका मतलब फोल्डर का नेम
डॉट से शुरू हो रहा है और एस मैंने बताया
कि आईडी आर से होता है य आपको बहुत सारे
सीटी चेंस में ऐसा मिल जाएगा कि आपको आईडी
नाम की एक फाइल मिलेगी उस फाइल का यूज
करके आप डायरेक्टली जो है बिना पासवर्ड के
और बिना किसी चीज के आप एसेट से कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं किसी यूजर पे ठीक है चलिए दिस
डायरेक्टरी कंटेंस थ ऑथेंटिकेशन कीज ट अला
यूजर टू ऑथेंटिकेट देम ऑन एंड देन एक्सेस
अ सर्वर चच ऑफ दिस कीज इज मोस्ट यूजफुल टू
अस कौन सी है आईडी आरस मैंने आपको बताया
ऑलरेडी सरी र से लिख दिया मैंने आईडी आर
एसए चलिए ये भी हो गया डाउनलोड फाइल टू
लोकल मशीन चेंज द परमिशन टू हां ठीक है
चलिए डाउनलोड करते हैं इस फाइल फ को
डाउनलोड कर ही चुके हैं मतलब हम लोग
ऑलरेडी ठीक है यहां पर हमरे पास रखी होगी
कहां गई आईडिया रस्ते ठीक है अब एक
इंपोर्टेंट चीज क्या होती है आपको इसकी
परमिशन चेंज करनी होती है 600 ठीक है ताकि
क्योंकि ये फाइल देखिए क्या है ये एक
सेंसिटिव फाइल है ठीक है तो ये अगर आप
नहीं करेंगे तो एस इसको लेगा ही नहीं अब
उसकी परमिशन चेंज करनी पड़ेगी इस कमांड से
सी मोड 600 नेम ठीक है ये आपने नस वा
सीरीज में पढ़ा होगा यूजर की होती है फिर
ग्रुप्स की होती है फिर अदर्स की होती है
परमिशन ठीक है फोर मतलब रीड ठीक है टू
मतलब राइट और वन मतलब एक्सक्यूट ये आपने
पढ़ा ही होगा ऑलरेडी नहीं पढ़ा तो स को
अच्छे से देख लीजिए इसलिए सारी चीजें आपस
में कहीं कहीं से रिलेटेड होती है चाहे आप
सी देने जा रहे हो कोई एग्जाम देने जा रहे
हो देने जा रहे हो या कुछ भी कर रहे हो
ठीक है चलिए तो कनेक्ट करने वाले हैं यहां
पर ना यूज फंशन लॉगइन ठीक है हम करना है
इसका यूज करना है और हमें एसस से कनेक्ट
करना है हम क्या करेंगे एस ठीक है मेरे
ख्याल से हान आई स्विच होता है एक बार चेक
कर लेता हूं ताकि कोई दिक्कत ना हो
आईन आई होना चाहिए हां ठीक है आई आईडी
अंडर आरस दे देते हैं हम यहां पर फिर हम
यहां पर अपना आईपी दे देते हैं पेस्ट कर
देते हैं
ओके तो हमने तीन चार बार ट्राई किया हमारा
कनेक्ट नहीं हुआ अब मैं आपको उसका रीजन
बताता हूं ठीक है हमारी फाइल या आईडी आर
से आपको कैट कर दिखाता हूं ये आईडी आरएस
से ठीक है इस तरीके से हमारा य प्राइवेट
की है इसके अंदर ठीक है अब हमने क्या किया
था हमने किया था एस हान आई ठीक है आईडी
अंडरस्कोर आरएस से हमने फाइल दिया ठीक है
फिर हमने क्या किया अपना यूजर नेम दिया
जॉन ठीक है और हमने यहां पर आईपी एड्रेस
को पेस्ट कर दिया एजट करके अब दिक्कत
हमारा कनेक्ट इसलिए नहीं हो रहा था ठीक है
हमने यूर सही नहीं दिया कहने का मतलब क्या
देखिए कने कर रहा हूं तोय क्लोज हो जा रहा
है अब इंपोर्टेंट चीज आपको ध्यान रखनी है
सीटीएफ है ठीक है इट ल अबाउट रेशन तो आपको
य हरज ट्राई करनी हैसे हमारा यूजर क्या था
र नाम था जॉन कैक्टस ठीक है तो दो चार 10
अटम के बाद मुझे रिलाइज हुआ इसका यूजर नेम
जो है वो जॉन नहीं कैक्टस नाम से ठीक है
ये आपको डन ट्रायल प ही है आपके
टोटल कैक्टस ठीक है इसको रन करूंगा तोय
आपको कनेक्शन मिल जाएगा य देखिए हमने कर
लिया एलेस करते हैं य पर हमारा एटी आ चुका
है कैट करते हैं एटी को फ्लैग मिल जाएगा
हमें यह रहा हमारा फ्लैग ठीक है फ्लैग
कॉपी कर लेते हैं आपको ध्यान ही रखना है
आपको हर चीज ट्राई करनी है ठीक है सारी
पॉसिबिलिटीज ये रियल लाइफ में भी है ठीक
है सीटीएफ और रियल लाइफ ला अंतर होता है
लेकिन आपको फिर भी काफी हद तक ये ट्राई
करना सिखा जाता है कि जो चीज आपको लग रहा
है कि नहीं यार ये नहीं हो सकता उसको भी
आपको ट्राई करना है ठीक है ना अगर सब लोग
य सोचेंगे नहीं हो सकता तो उसमें ही कुछ
होगा और सब लोग उसको छोड़ते जाएंगे तो वो
आपको नहीं करना है तो एसएमबी का बेसिक
एक्सशन आपको समझ में आ गया होगा अगर मिस
कन्फेशन रह जाता है एनोनिमस लॉगिन रह जाता
है किसी भी शेयर पे ठीक है इवन आप ए कर
सकते हैं तो उसके बारे में हम लोग देखेंगे
आगे जाके ठीक है हाडा टूल का इस्तेमाल
करके वो भी देखेंगे हम लोग ठीक है तो इस
टाइप मकरेशन जो है वो खतरनाक साबित हो
सकते हैं चलिए ये बेसिक हो गया एक्सटिंग
एसएमबी अब हम बात करते हैं टेलनेट की अब
टेलनेट के बारे में तो मैंने आपको इतनी
बार का द कि कु बताने लायक बचा ही नहीं है
ज्यादा ठीक है बेसिक हम सीधे आंसर करेंगे
चलिए ट यहां पर टेट के बारे में थोड़ा
दिया हुआ है रिप्लेसमेंट दिया हुआ है बता
चुका हूं मैं एच यूज करते हैं इसकी जगह कक
क्योंकि आंसर हो चाहिए टेलनेट आपका क्लियर
टेस्ट होता है ठीक है और ऐसे
होता है चलिए क्या लिखा है ओके वही चज ट
का य पर ी दिया हुआ है व्ट इस टेलनेट
टेलनेट क्या है तो एप्लीकेशन प्रोटोकॉल
यही लिखा हुआ य पर वही डाल देते हैं
एप्लीकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल सही है व्ट है स्लोली रिप्लेस
नेट किसने रिप्लेस कर दिया एने कर दिया
व्ट वड यू कनेक्ट ू नेट सर्वर पोट हाड सरी
ड नहीं ये तो भाई इस क्या ही पूछ रहा है
पर कोई नहीं नेट हमें करना है किस 10 10
10.3 पे पोर्ट नंबर 23 प कनेक्ट करना है
ये कमांड डालेंगे द लैक ऑफ वट मीन ट ल नेट
कम्युनिकेशन इ इन प्लेन टेक्स्ट लैक ऑफ वट
क्या नहीं है लैक ऑफ एंक्रिप्शन ठीक है
इंक्रिप्शन चलिए अ टेलनेट का इंट्रो हो
गया एमेट करना शुरू करते हैं टेलनेट को
ठीक है अगेन वही चीज एमेशन के क्या होता
है ठीक है पोट स्कंग से शुरू कीजिए हमें
मैप सेए रिकमेंड है हम आई नेटवर्क में
टेस्टिंग में तो खास करके आपको ये सब चीज
करनी है ठीक है ना चलिए आप पीटी एग्जाम
में देखेंगे उसमें भीय चीज रहेंगी आपको
करने के लिए आपको नेटवर्क दिया जाएगा
उसमें आपको एशन खुद से करना होगा डिवाइस
कौन से है उम क्या पोट रन हो रहा है फायर
वल है कि नहीं है तो बायपास कैसे करें र
वो तो हमने सब देख ही लिया कैसे करना है
वो चीजें चलिए एक्सपोर्टेशन पार्ट प है
अभी हम फिलहाल हाउ मेनी पोर्ट्स आर ओपन ऑन
द टारगेट मशीन अगेन वही चीज चलिए स्कैन
करते हैं ऑलरेडी हमने कर लिया था ना यार
वही मशीन है कि दूसरी है दूसरी है ओके
हमें टर्मिनेट करनी पड़ेगी इसको स्टार्ट
करनी पड़ेगी दूसरी मशीन ओबवियस है वहां पर
तो कनेट रन नहीं हो रहा था हमने ऑलरेडी
स्कैन कर ही लिया
था चलिए अब देखिए य पर लिखा हुआ है हाउ
मेनी पोर्ट्स आर ओपन ऑन द टारगेट मशीन
व्हाट पोर्ट इज दिस इसका ओवरल रिशन तो जा
रहा है कि एक ही पोर्ट ओपन है तभी तो लिखा
है व्ट पोर्ट इज दिस ना इज दिस कैसे लिख
सकता तो होप फुली एक ही पोर्ट होने वाला
है सही आंसर है चलिए ट्रक वाले भी कुछ ऐसा
ऐसा हिंट दे देते हैं आपको कि आप एक दो
आंसर खुद ही बता देंगे क्या होने वाला है
अभी कौन सा प ब प होने वाला
है नंबर पूछ रहा य पर एक दो तीन च च ट का
पोट होने वाला है य पर मेरे ल से हमें
जरूरत पड़ सकती है फुल ए स्कन करने
की आई एडस आ गया हमा पास आने वाला 15
सेकंड
में परक चा दिया हु तो फल करंग ठीक है
वैसे भी कोई प कर रहे एक बार आप ओवरल स्कन
कर लीजिए ठीक है से आप कुछ और टल भी
इस्तेमाल कर दीजिए ठीक है स्कैन करने के
लिए जल्दी से और फिर उसके बा टेल जो स्कन
है उसको रन कीजिए बाद में ठीक है और एक
ओवरव्यू ले लीजिए ऊपर से क्या है मशीन में
कैसे है ठीक है
चलिए हम लोग क्या करने वाले य पर आईपी
एड्रेस आ चुका है इस आई एड्रेस कॉपी करते
हैं सिंपली यहां पर पेस्ट कर देते हैं और
रन कर देते हैं सॉरी नवी लगाना भूल गया
मैं नवी मतलब वस आउटपुट ठीक है देखते जैसे
मिलेगा ये पोट आउटपुट म ओपन है उसको हम
लोग तुरंत कंट्रोल स रोक देंगे एक पोर्ट
ओपन ना चाहिए बस
एटलीस्ट स पोर्ट इ इ अनसाइंड बट स्टिल
लिस्ट द प्रोटोकॉल इट यूजिंग व्ट
प्रोटोकॉल इज
दिस पोट इ अनसाइंड स्ट प्रोल यूजिंग य
देखते हैं क्या आउटपुट जो है व आता है अभी
तक तो कोई भी पोडिस कवर नहीं हुआ है ओपन
वेट करना
पड़ेगा ओके यह देखिए कमाल की बात नाउ रन द
ए स्कन विदाउट द हान प हान टैग हाउ मेनी
पोर्ट्स शो अप एस ओपन सही है भाई इसको
कैसे पता कि हम आ यूज करने वाले हैं सही
है
भाई बढ़िया वेट करते
हैं कभी कभी ऐसा भी होता है रिर कंडीशन
में कि आपको ज्यादा हैवी प कर की से आपको
इक्ट रिजल्ट मिल जाते हैं इसलिए मेरे खल
से यहां पर वो चीज लिखी हुई है जो मैंने
आपसे कही थी लडी की एक तरीका जनरल आप पहले
एक बेसिक पोट स्कन कर लीजिए कुछ और ट कर
लीजिए सिर्फ मत रहिए और फिर आप साथ में जो
है बेसिक फुल एमेशन को लगाइए लेकिन एक बार
जो है ऊपर से और आपको मिल जाना
चाहिए चलिए बाकी अपनी अपनी मैथोलॉजी है
कोई उसम वो नहीं है फिक्स कांस्टेंट नहीं
है कोई जैसे आप चाहे वैसे कर सकते
हैं इसका वेट करते हैं हम लोग इसके फिनिश
होने का पूरा वीडियो को आप स्किप कर सकते
हैं वैसे लेकिन तब तक आप अपनी तरफ से चीज
सोचते रहि जोड़ते रहि क्या आ सकता है क्या
आ सकता है चीज आपको सोचते रहनी है ठीक है
ना
उम्मीद करता हूं मैं कि आप नोट्स पूरे बना
रहे होंगे जितने भी चीज कंप्लीट नोट की
जरत नहीं है शर्ट न बना रहे काफी है ठीक
ऊपर से देखो तो हो जाए टॉपिक ऐसा है कि
आपको एक याद नहीं
होगा ठीक है और या रखनी भी नहीं है लेकिन
आपको मोटे मोटे त पता आना चाहि क्या है
ठीक है
ना अभ य पर लग रहा काफी टाइम लगने वाला
है साथ में एक और जगह हम य पर स्कन को जो
अपने स्टार्ट कर देते सिपल सा हम य पर
करते हैं नॉर्मल पोट स्कैन हान दे देते
हैं य पर कोई भी पोट ओपन नहीं आ इस
तो ठीक है कोई पोट ओपन नहीं है हेयर व कैन
सी बाय असंग नेट टू नॉन स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट इ
नॉट पार्ट ऑफ द कॉमन पोर्ट लिस्ट पोर्ट ट
पोर्टेंट टू ट्रा एवरी एंगल टिंग इमेशन य
गदर विल ब इफॉर्म र एक्स ठीक है देखिए ये
बहुत एक इंपोर्टेंट चीज है ठीक है ना बहुत
ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट चीज है ये उसमें ये
लिखा हुआ है कि टट का जो स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट
होता है ठीक है उससे हमने चेंज करके इसको
एक नॉन स्टैंडर्ड पोर्ट यानी कोई रैंडम
पोर्ट अ साइन कर दिया है ठीक है तो ये
बहुत जरूरी होता है कि आपक जो ए मैप बाय
डिफॉल्ट रन करता है तो वो टॉप 1000 पोर्ट
को स्कैन करता है तो ये बहुत जरूरी होता
है कि आप स्कैन कंप्लीट करें मैंने फिर से
चीज बोलता हूं कि एक बार भले आप ऊपर से
स्कैन कर ले लेकिन लास्ट में आपको फुल
डिटेल स्कैन करनी ही चाहिए क्योंकि उसमें
आपको क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन एक्स्ट्रा मिल
सकती है ये आपको नहीं पता ठीक है और फुल
पो करते आपको लगता है कि यार चैलेंज तो
कितना आसान था ठीक है तो इस बात को ध्यान
रख
चलिए इसको कंप्लीट कर देते हैं अभी के लिए
इसको य पर क्लोज कर देते हैं एक हमें कोई
पोर्ट मिलेगा यहां पर कब तक मिलता है इसका
वेट करना पड़ेगा आगे बढ़ते रहते हैं थोड़े
बहुत जना बढ़ सकते हैं हम लोग बे न टाइटल
रिटर्न टू अस व्ट डू वी थिंक दिस पोर्ट
कुड बी यूज फॉर ओके तो अभी तो नहीं बढ़
पाएंगे हम लोग आगे वेट करना ही पड़ेगा
पहले देखते हैं यहां पर आप चाहे तो इस
वीडियो को स्किप कर दीजिए कोई मतलब नहीं
है मेरे वीडियो को कट करने का
बारबार वी स्किप कर सकते हैं आप थोड़ा सा
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है उसमें बाकी बात हम लोग
करते रहते हैं कि आप लिंकन प आके हमें
फॉलो कर सकते हैं और फॉलो सिर्फ फॉलो करने
से ऐसा नहीं कि फॉलो कर लिए भाई क्या मिल
रहा है फॉलो करने से ऐसा नहीं है वो फायदा
मिलेगा फायदा बता रहा ह आपको ठीक
है आपको मिलेगा यहां पर कोई भी चीज का कोई
भी हमारी तरफ से अलर्ट आएगा पोस्ट आएगी
कोई भी चीज आएगी इंपोर्टेंट ठीक है वो
आपको मिल जाएगी बहुत सारे कोर्स लच करने
वाले आगे को कोर्सेस डिस्काउंट भी रहेंगे
सर्टिफिकेशन पर भी डिस्काउंट रहेंगे बहुत
स चीज रहेंगी तो वो यस बात हम फर्स्ट कम
फर्स्ट सर्विसेस पे ही करेंगे जो भी चीजें
करेंगे ठीक है चाहे वो चैलेंज हो कोई बेटर
टेस्टिंग हो या फिर आपके लिए कुछ
डिस्काउंट्स हो सब कुछ आपको वैसे ही मिलता
है तो इस पे आप कनेक्ट रहेंगे तो आपका ही
फायदा रहेगा ज्यादा फायदा आपका ही रहेगा
ठीक है ना तो मैं तो कहूंगा फॉलो कर लीजिए
भाई और
अच्छ आपको सो बाकी चीज जितने भी हमारी तर
से प्रोवाइड की जा सकती है वो पक्का
प्रोवाइड की जाएंगी ठीक है चलिए ओके सो
यहां पर बहुत ज्यादा टाइम लग रहा था इसलिए
मुझे इसको पॉज करना पड़ गया ठीक है मैं
आपको रेली बताता हूं कि से स्कैन करेंगे
तो यहां पर आपको जो पोर्ट ओपन मिलेगा वो
रहेगा 8012 ठीक है इसको हम सबमिट कर देते
हैं और उसको मैं आपको मैनली चेक करा देता
हूं य चीज ठीक है पोर्ट 8012 स्कैन करूंगा
य पर डायरेक्टली ठीक है ये आपको कंप्लीट
स्कैन करना है मुझे चक ये लेक्चर कंप्लीट
करना है ठीक है तो हम पास टाइम वेस्ट करने
कोई मतलब नहीं है यहां पर ये होगा तो 8012
यहां पर पोर्ट ओपन आ चुका है ठीक है यहां
प सर्विस अननोन है अब यहां पर देखते हैं
अगला क्वेश्चन क्या था द पोर्ट इज
अनअसाइंड बट स्टिल ट्स द प्रोटोकॉल इट्स
यूजिंग व्ट प्रोटोकॉल इज दिस कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल यहां प यूज हो रहा है य पर टीसी
प्रोटोकॉल यूज हो रहा है ई सर्विस तो पूछा
नहीं गया है प्रोटोकॉल पूछा गया है ठीक है
तो मार दीजिए टीसीपी उसको चलिए आगे बढ़ते
हैं बेस्ड ऑन द टाइटल रिटर्न टू अस व्हाट
डू वी थिंक दिस प्रोटोकॉल कुड बी यूज्ड
फॉर यह प्रोटोकॉल किस काम के लिए यूज हो
सकता है
आसर फर्मेट में है थ देखना पड़ेगा आ
देखते बल टू पब प काम
करते करने ा करते हैं ठीक है हमा पास
है हो चका
है से आंसर उसी के अंदर मिलने वाले हमलोग
को पेस्ट करते इसको ठीक है और पोटरा क्या
ओके बैक डोर ओके ओके स्कज बैक डोर तो ये
क्या हो सकता है अ बैक
डोर सही है चलिए ट बिलोंग टू इट कुड
बिलोंग टू स्कड़ अब इसको देख के आपको क्या
समझ में आया इसको देख के आपको ये समझ में
आया कि ये सिस्टम जो था ठीक है ये ऑलरेडी
कंप्रोमाइज कर लिया गया था किसी स्कड़ नाम
के बंदे द्वारा और उसने जान बूझ के पोर्ट
8012 जो कि डिफॉल्ट पोर्ट नहीं होता है
उसपे टेलनेट सर्विस चला रखी थी ताकि जब वो
चाहे अपना इसमें कोई भी काम कर सके ठीक है
मलेश इटेड से जो जो करना चाहे वो कर सकता
है ठीक है तोब चकि उसने किया है लेकिन
उसने कोई ऑथेंटिकेशन तो लगाया नहीं है इस
पे ठीक है तो हम भी कर सकते हैं ना वो
काम चलिए पर हम देखते हैं आगे चीजें क्या
है यहां
पर आते हैं हम लोग यहां पर एक्सप्लोइटिंग
टेलनेट पे ठीक है देखिए यहां पर क्या हुआ
है यहां पर फिर वही चीज दी हुई है अब
देखिए अगेन वही चीज आती है कि यहां पर भी
सीवी वाला तो हो ही सकता है वो सीवी वाला
तो खैर यूनिवर्सल ट्रुथ है एक तरीके से
जिस भी चीज के लिए वल्नरेबल ऐसे अवेलेबल
है डायरेक्ट उसको आप यूज कर सकते हैं अब
यहां पर हम क्या करने वाले हैं एमेशन वाला
ठीक है हमने क्या किया य पर ये फाइंड कि ट
चालू हुआ ठीक है हमने कनेक्ट कसे किया अब
रिवर्स शल य पर क्या होता है रिवर्स शल
क्या होता है मैंने बताया बा र् बताया था
अगर आपका जो विक्टिम है ठीक है टिम वो
आपसे कनेक्ट हो रहा है मतलब आप उसको पट
भेज रहे हैं तुम उससे कनेक्ट करो तो
रिवर्स शल होगा अगर आप उससे कनेक्ट कर रहे
तो वो कौन सा शल होगा बा शल होगा ठीक है
मैंने आपको बता रखी है
चलिए य पर करना क्या है ले कनेट नेट पोर्ट
ठीक है कनेक्ट करना है कनेक्ट हमारा हो
गया गेट इ ओपने ठीक व्ट वेलकम मैसेज ड व
रिसीव क्या वेलकम मैसेज मिला है हमको
वेलकम मैसेज मिला है यह वाला ठीक है स्
बैक डोर और डॉट लगा हुआ है आगे कॉपी करके
इसको पेस्ट कर देते हैं यहां पर सबमिट
चलिए लेट्स टिंग सम कमांड टू वी गेट अ
रिटर्न ऑन एनी इनपुट वी एंटर इन नेट सेशन
कोई कमांड हम डाल के देख ए डाला तो हम
रिटर्न मिला डट हेल्प ठीक है तो ऐसा तो
कोई नहीं मिला एक्चुअली ठीक है देखिए हम
टस स्टें लेटस चेक टू सी इफ वी आर टपिंग ब
सिस्टम कमांड हमने जो भी टाइप किया हमने
एलस टाइप डॉट हेल्प आ गया ठीक है तो क्या
वो हो भी रहा है कि नहीं हो रहा है डॉट
हेल्प डाला तो क्या आ गया डॉट रन और फिर
कमांड ठीक है इसका मतलब हम क्या करना होगा
होप फुली डॉट रन करके अगर हम कोई कमांड
डालते हैं तो रन हो जाएगी ऐसा होना चाहिए
अब देखिए ये स्टक हो जा रहा है यहां पर
आउटपुट नहीं दे रहा है मतलब वो कमांड तो
रन हो रही है मेरे ख्याल से आउटपुट नहीं आ
रहा है उस चीज का इसको रोकते हैं कंट्रोल
सी से रोकते
हैं ओ कोई नहीं दोबारा कनेक्ट कर लेते हैं
ठीक
है
भते है टेलनेट आईपी हमारे पास
था आईपी हमारे पास यहां पर है
ही 8012 पोर्ट करेक्ट हमने कर लिया है ठीक
है डॉट हेल्प रन करने से हमें मिल चुका है
कि हम डॉट रन करके कोई कमांड रन कर सकते
हैं सिस्टम वाली ठीक है हमारी कमांड क्या
होगी क्क हम कमांड का आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा
है तो हम क्या करने वाले देखिए यहां परने
क्या किया है टीसीपी डम टूल क सकते हैं आप
ठीक है ये कमांड डालने सते हैं कि अगर आप
यहां पर ओप य कर रहे तो आप यहां पर
इंटरफेस का नेम होगा वो टन जीरो होगा अगर
आप कर तो आप इंटरफेस का नाम ये होने वाला
है इसलिए य पर इंटरफेस नेम चेंज है बाकी
कमांड सेम है इससे हम क्या कर सकते हैं
इससे हम देख सकते हैं कि कुछ यहां पर पास
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है कि नहीं अब रिक्वेस्ट
कैसे आएगी जब हम रिवर्सल जनरेट करेंगे तब
आएगी ठीक है ना मतलब क्या य पर मैं एक नए
टर्मिनल में अगर खोल दू इसको पेस्ट करके य
लिसन करना स्टार्ट कर देगा ठीक है य
स्टार्ट कर चुका है लिसनिंग ठीक है जैसे
ही जैसे ही यहां पर कोई भी कनेक्शन आता है
ठीक है वो आपको दिखा देगा मतलब य पर कुछ
रिक्वेस्ट की गई है वो रिक्वेस्ट चेक
करेंगे मेरे ख्याल से पि से चेक पि सेही
चेक कर रहा है ठीक हैता हं आपको देखिए हम
क्या करने वाले पिंग करना है लोकल
ट्रैकिंग मशीन का आईपी डाल केव ठीक इसका
मतलब अगर य पर जो कमांड डाल रहे हैं हम हम
उसका आउटपुट तो मिल नहीं रहा है ठीक है हम
उसका आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा है लेकिन हमें
क्या मिल रहा है आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा पर
हम क्या मिल रहा है उसका क्या मिल रहा है
एक्यूट हो रही कमांड ठीक आट मतलब आउटपुट
नहीं मिलेगा परट हो रही कमांड अब उसको चेक
कैसे किया जाए तर नेट कर लीजिए तो ये जो
तरीका लगा रहे फालतू है मतलब य करने की
जरत नहीं सकते ले ठीक है नेट नहीं है उसम
तो ट्राई कर सकते पि तो होगा ही तो इस
दिखाता हूं आपको तो मैं क्या करूंगा यहां
पर पहले मैं अपना आईपी चेक कर लेता हूं
मेरा आईपी यहां पर क्या
है e5 का ठीक है 10 10 122 2 48 ये है
मेरा आईपी एड्रेस ठीक है
कॉपी मैं इस रिमोट मशीन से कहूंगा कि भाई
रिमोट मशीन पिंग करो मेरा आईपी एड्रेस विथ
नंबर ऑफ पैकेट्स वन ठीक है ये देखिए जैसे
ही मैंने किया यहां पर पिंग आ गया इसका
मतलब यहां हम जो भी कमांड दे रहे हैं वो
एक्चुअली एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है हमें उसका
आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा है पर वो कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है तो हम देख सते क्या
नेट कट है नेटकट यूज करेगा ठीक है हमें
पिंग रिक्वेस्ट मिली मिल गई ठीक है
चलिए कर रहा है य पर एक नेटकट का रिवर्स
के लिए पेलो क्रिएट कर रहा है ठीक है अय
इससे क्यों कर रहा है पता नहीं मेरे ख्याल
से हम डायरेक्टली ट्राई कर सकते हैं इसको
वर्क करना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से नेट कट ठीक
है कनेक्ट करना है हमारे आईपी एडस प पोट
ओके
सॉरी
लिख देता हूं मैं
10.10.1 248 प कनेक्ट करो भाई पोट 4444 पे
ठीक
है चलिए यहां पर हम क्या करते लिसना चालू
करते
हैं हम पोर्ट प पोर्ट 4444 प लिंग चालू कर
दिए है और य से अपनी कमांड को एक्यूट कर
रहे हैं ठीक है देखते क्या आता है यहां पर
नहीं बना इसका देखते क्या दिक्कत हो रही
है ट वड ड द जनरे पे स्टार्ट
विथ एक बार ट्रा करते इस प को भी करने का
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है देखते क्या आता
है चलिए न्यू टब ओपन करते हैं य पर पेस्ट
करते य कोई फाइल नहीं कट कर रहे ठीक है
कोई फाइल नहीं कट हो रही य पर य पर भी एक
टेक्स्ट प कट होगा उसके फर्मेट में होगा य
पर देना है अपना आई एडस देना है
10 10 और आई एडस क्या था यहां पर
और आई एडस क्या था हमारा
10 10
122 एंड
248 122 248 य हरा आई एड्रेस हो गया ठीक
है लोकल पोट दे दिया है सब कुछ सही हैते
क्या आता है सामने य
पर
ट करते हैं य आर का मतलब हा य आर का मतलब
है कि एक्सपोर्ट कर रट में मतलब यही पर
दिखा दो सामने ठीक है ना क्या आने वाला है
जनरेट कर रहा है का टाइम लग रहा
या देखते
है क्या आता है यहां
पर चलिए आ गया य पर हमारा यह हमारा एमके
फिफ ओके ठीक है ठीक है सही है सही है यह
हमारा पूरा कट है ड ठीक य ने का पेलोड
नहीं है पर य नेट का इस्तेमाल कर रहा हैते
न देखेंगे तो नेट की वही सेम कमांड यूज कर
रहा है ठीक है बट य इसको इवोक अलग तरीके
से कर रहा है ठीक है ताकि आप उसको बायपास
कर सके चलिए एमके फ स्टार्ट हो रहा है
इसको मैं पेस्ट करूंगा डॉट रन और उसको
पेस्ट कर
दूंगा गया मेरा लग रहा
है ओके कोई नहीं दोबारा टाइप करना पड़ेगा
कर लेते हैं दोबारा टाइप इस बार जल्दी
जनरेट हो जाएगा ये
चीज लोकल होस्ट हमारा क्या था लोकल होस्ट
हमारा था वापस से देख लेते हैं यहां पर 10
10 122
248 10 10 122
248 जनरेट करते हैं वापस से इस बार जल्दी
जाना
चाहिए हमारा जो पेलोड है वो स्टार्ट हो
रहा था एम के फीफो से ठीक है ये हो गया अब
हमारा लिनर चालू है ही ऑलरेडी मेरे ख्याल
से लिनर हमने चालू कर रखा है पहले से ठीक
है य हमारा पे बन तैयार है परे प को
डायरेक्टली कॉपी
करेंगे य पर न के बाद इसको पेस्ट कर देंगे
और उसको रन करते हैं य देखिए कनेक्शन
हमारा रिसीव हो गया य पर अब हमसे यहां पर
करेंगे क्या एस कोई भी कमांड मिल जाएगा फग
हमारा मिल गया कट करते
इसको
ये हमारा फ्लैग जो है आ गया हमने क्या
यहां पर एक्सपर्ट किया अभी अभी टेलनेट
ठीक है ी करते हैं इसको और इसको यहां पर
हम करते हैं पेस्ट ठीक है टेलनेट से क्या
हुआ हमारा एक्सप्लोइटेशन सॉरी ये तो कुछ
और
था कमांड
ला पेलोड ठीक है अच्छा जो लिसनिंग कमांड
क्या होगी लिसनिंग कमांड होगी येन एलवी प
चलिए ठीक है ग्रेट फ्लैग हम दे देते हैं
यहां पर तो आपको भी मैं यहां पर चलिए ठीक
है टेलनेट हो गया टट को हमने कइड किया
टेलनेट में हमने क्या किया यहां पर क्या
था एक ब कीने रिकॉल कीजिए कि हमने टोटल जो
है अभी तक टेलनेट के लिए किया क्या है
पूरा ऊपर से देखिए यहां पर स्क्रोल कीजिए
समझिए क्या किया
हमने समझ में आया आपको टलेट का जो पोर्ट
था वो ओपन था ठीक है और उसमें कोई भी
ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं था ज टट का पोर्ट ओपन था
हमारा कोई उस ऑथेंटिकेशन नहीं था हम वहां
पर सिस्टम कमांड रन कर पा रहे थे अब
सिस्टम कमांड प हमने क्या रन किया चकि
हमें वहां प आउटपुट नहीं मिल रहा था तो हम
इसलिए वहां पर रिवर्स शल पाने के लिए हमने
नेट थ्रू जो है रिवर्सल किया अगर टट हमें
डायरेक्टली आउटपुट दे रहा होता तो हमारा
काम वहीं प खत्म हो जाता पर टरनेट हमें
आउटपुट नहीं दे रहा था ठीक है इसलिए हमने
इतने लंबे मेथड मतलब जो है चूज किया
रिवर्स शल वाला चलिए तो ये भी कंप्लीट हो
गया
है ओके सो हमने एसएमबी का नेट का जो है
एक्सप्लोइटेशन देख लिया अब हम एफटीपी पे आ
रहे हैं एफटीपी में आप समझ गए होंगे
ऑलरेडी क्या होने वाला है ठीक है ये आपको
बेसिक तो पता ही है एफटीपी का मैं मैंने
आपको ऑलरेडी बता रखा है ठीक है एफटीपी में
ये ये चीज मैंने आपको बता रखी होगी एक्टिव
वर्सेस पैसिव बताया था मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी
कि एक्टिव जो एफटीपी कनेक्शन होता है ठीक
है उसमें क्लाइंट ओपन सपोर्ट एंड लिसन
यानी क्लाइंट ओपन करता है और लिसन कर रहा
होता है ठीक है सर्वर इज रिक्वायर्ड टू
एक्टिवली कनेक्ट टू इट सर्वर उससे कनेक्ट
होता है ठीक है और पैसिव एफटीपी कनेक्शन
में क्या होता है सर्वर एक ओपन कि रता है
पोर्ट ठीक है लिसन कर रहा होता है और
क्लाइंट कनेक्ट होता है ठीक है ये डिफरेंस
है एक्टिव और पैसिव एफटीपी कनेक्शन का
चलिए और ये भी मैंने आपको बताया था कि
यहां पर कमांड का इंफॉर्मेशन कमांड
इंफॉर्मेशन एंड डाटा सेपरेट चैनल्स में
जाते हैं ठीक है दो अलग-अलग सेपरेट चैनल
होता है इसमें कमांड और डेटा आ जाते हैं
टा चैनल अलग होता है स और कमांड का जो
चैनल है वो अलग होता है ठीक है ना यू कुड
ओनली एंटर कमांड्स इन बिटवीन डेटा
ट्रांसफर ठीक है व्हिच वुडन बी एफिशिएंट
फॉर आइजर लास्ट फाइल ट्रांसफर और स्लो
इंटरनेट क ठीक है ना समझ में आ गया आपको
यहां पे ये लिखा हुआ है कि देखिए यहां बता
रहा आपको अच्छे से एकदम सब चैनल इज अ वे
ऑफ बीइंग एबल टू सेंड कमांड्स टू सर्वर
विदाउट हैविंग टू वेट फॉर द करेंट डेटा
ट्रांसफर टू फिनिश कहने का मतलब क्या कहने
का मतलब ये कि अगर एक ही चैनल होता ठीक है
आप डेटा ट्रांसफर कर रहे हैं उस कमांड
भेजना है आपको तो कैसे भेजेंगे दिक्कत हो
जाएगी ना इसलिए दो अलग-अलग चैनल है आप वेट
करेंगे र होने का ठीक है तो बेकार तरीका
है इसलिए हम य पर मल्टीपल चैनल का
इस्तेमाल करते हैं चलिए व्ट कम्युनिकेशन
मॉडल ड एफटीपी यूज एफटीपी वही वही यहां पर
भी होगा क्लाइंट सर्वर रिपस रिक्वेस्ट
देखते हैं क्या क्या लेता है चलिए क्लाइंट
सर्वर हो गया एफटीपी एटीपी का स्टैंडर्ड
पोर्ट क्या 21 हाउ मेनी मोड कनेक्शन आ देर
दो मोड होते हैं ठीक है चलिए अब एटीपी के
न्यूमरेशन की बारी आती है इसको क्लोज करते
हम टर्मिनेट करते स्टार्ट करते हैं
इसको
अशन में क्या होने वाला है दो तरीका अगेन
वही कि अगर आपका एफटीपी का कोई ऐसा वर्जन
रन हो रहा है जो कि वल्नरेबल है किसी सीवी
से तो डायरेक्टली एक्सट हो जाएगा ठीक है
अगर वैसा कुछ नहीं है तो अगेन वही चीज आती
है अनिमस लगिन वाली जो आपको मैंने बताई है
ठीक है तो ये रूम बेसिकली कन्फेशन प ही
बेस्ड था जतर ठीक है अल्टरनेट तरीका एक्
डी सब देख सकते हैं यहां पर लिखा है कितने
पोर्ट है वन ट्राई करते हैं टू ट्राई करते
हैं टू हो गया दो पोर्ट होंगे इसको स्कैन
कर ही देते हैंक नहा
डाल दे रहे हैं व्ट पोर्ट इ एफटीपी रनिंग
ऑन 21 ट्राई करते हैं ये सही है व्हाट
वेरिएंट ऑफ एफटीपी इज रनिंग ऑन इट एक दो
तीन च पा 6 ठीक है वीएस एफटीपी हो सकता है
शायद देखते हैं खैर इसका आईपी एड्रेस आने
का वेट करते हैं तो फिर हम लोग यहां पर जो
है ए स्कैन चालू करते
हैं बेसिकली ये चीज आपको समझ में आ रही
होगी कि एनोनिमस लॉगइन क्या है मिस
कंफिल इन या फिर विदाउट क्रेडेंशियल अगर
लॉगइन अलाउड है कोई पोट सा ओपन है ठीक है
कोई सर्विस रन हो रही है तो उसे कितनी
दिक्कत हो सकती है ये सब मिस कन्फेशन पे
है अब यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं कि एक दो
आईपी मतलब आईपी पे एक दो पोर्ट चालू है
वैसे केस थोड़ी ऐसा मिस कन्फेशन होगा
बड़े-बड़े कंपनी नेटवर्क होता है बहुत
सारे सिस्टम होते हैं उन सब में बहुत सारे
पोर्ट सर्विस रन हो रही होती है उन सब में
ऐसी ऐसी चीजें छूट जाती हैं ठीक है इसलिए
यहां पर जो है पेंटेस्ट जरूरी है आप क्या
कर रहे हैं आप यहां पर ए यूज कर रहे हैं
आप h स् लगा रहे हैं वो आपको पूरा डिटेल
बता दे रहा है कि भाई आपका ये ये पोर्ट पे
एनोनिमस लॉगिन चालू है ठीक है पर वो तो
ऐसा नहीं कर रहे हैं ना वो सेट कर रहे हैं
तो वो पोर्ट्स थोड़ी कर रहे हैं बट के
पूरा उनके दिमाग से निकल जाता है क्योंकि
उन्हें ये चीजें नहीं पता है उनको ये
टर्मिनोलॉजी तरीके नहीं पता है जो आपको
पता है ठीक है ये डिफरेंस होता है क
उन्होंने टेस्ट के लिए चालू किया एनोनिमस
लॉगिन काम कर लिया बंद करना भूल गए ये
बिल्कुल ओबवियस है ये होता है ठीक है वही
वाली बात है और आपको सीटीएस में तो खैर ये
इतना जदा मिलेगा देखने की आप जानते ही है
सीटीएस में आपको ये भरभर के मिलने वाला है
इस टाइप की चीजें आपको मिस कन्फेशन ठीक है
क्योंकि ज्यादातर कोई ओल्ड सिस्टम यज नहीं
करता ट तो लोग कर ही लेते हैं ठीक है वो
तो आपको उसता है कम चांस में मिलने का
लेकिन मिस कन्फ फिगरेशन तो बहुत ज्यादा
कॉमन है ठीक है चलिए आई एड्रेस हमारा आ
चुका है इसको हम यहां पर क्या करेंगे ए
मैप से बेसिक 1000 पोर्ट स्कैन करेंगे हम
लोग सिंपल स्कैन करते हैं आवी लगा के कुछ
और से नहीं लगाएंगे इस पे
भी चलिए दो पट आ गया क्या नहीं एक ही पट
आया 21 ठीक है मतलब एक पट ऊपर भी कहीं ओपन
होगा चलिए कोई नहीं देख लेंगे बाद में के
ऊपर ओपन होगा एफटीपी रन हो रहा है व्ट
वेरिएंट ऑफ एफटीपी इ रनिंग मेरे ख्याल से
इसके लिए हमें कनेक्ट ही करना पड़ेगा हम
सीधे नहीं बता सते कौन सा रन हो रहा है
एफटीपी करते हैं क्या
गया एफटीपी करते
हैं हम एफटीपी के अंदर आ चुके हैं कोई
नहीं एफटीपी करते हैं
अपना आई एड्रेस कॉपी कर लेते
हैं कर दिया हमने य पर कनेक्ट कर दिया
इस यहां पर नाम तो नहीं लिखा है कुछ
सर्विस लिखा
सिंपल व्ट वेरिएंट ऑफ एटी रनिंग नट मेरे
खल से हम य पर ए के स्विच का ही इस्तेमाल
करना पड़ जाएगा कोई नहीं व भी कर लेते हैं
हम करते ए स्कन प देते प 2 स्कन करना है
हम स्क्रिप्ट रन करनी है आई हमने कर दिया
चलिए पता है क्या
एटीपी लगन अलाउड वर्जन वर्जन वर्जन ठीक है
वीएस एफटीपीडी सही कहा था मैंने ीस एटी
पीडी है व एस एफटीपीडी य काफी जगह देखने
को मिलेगा चलिए मा कौन सवर यूज हो रहा है
ठीक है सते य पर अमस लॉगिन है कि नहीं
एनोनिमस लॉगिन के लिए आपको यूजर नेम
एनोनिमस देना होता है ठीक है पासवर्ड में
कुछ नहीं देना होता है ठीक है करने कर
ट्राई करते हैं हालांकि इसने रेडी बता
दियास लगिन इनेबल्ड है ठीक है तो हमें अब
चेक करने की जरूरत तो नहीं है लेकिन फिर
भी हमें पता है तो हम कर लेते हैं कनेक्ट
देते हैं इसको एंटर करते हैं यूजर नेम में
हम
एनोनिमस देंगे पासवर्ड में कुछ नहीं देंगे
कनेक्ट हमारा हो चुका है एलस करेंगे फइल
हमारे सामने आ गई ठीक है एक फाइल हमारे
सामने पड़ी हुई है पब्लिक नोटिस इसको गेट
करते हैं
पहले ओके सॉरी पब्लिक नोटिस नाम से य फाइल
है ट करते डायरेक्टली हो गया चलिए एग्जिट
करते हैं इसको
फल मिल गई होगी कट
पब्लिक पब्लिक नोट इसम क्या चीज पास आई
होप एवरीवन
रबल ल कै आट रूटीन
सिस्टम ो रिकमेंड कमें की स्पेलिंग कर कोई
नहीं एपिंग एनी स डटा यर्स माइक रने माइक
मिल गया है य पर फाइल का नेम पूछ रहा है
कौन सी फाइल मिली है फाइल मिली है पब्लिक
नोटिस एक्स यूजर नेम इसम क्या मिला रने
मिला है
माइक क्या कर सकते
अला पास ठीक है इस प जा नहीं सकते सते माइ
यूजरनेम से बस करने कर सकते मेरे ल से य
पर वही होने वाला है आगे ब फोर्स का ठीक
है
हा बाकी
प्रो ठीक है पर नहीं दिखाया गया उसको भी
कवर करेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है सिपल है ठीक है अब देखिए इसका ये पूरा
ब्रेकडाउन आपको मैकेनिज्म समझाया कि यहां
पर दिया हुआ है क्या है हाइड्रा टूल का
नाम है ठीक है हान t4 नंबर ऑफ पैल कनेक्शन
एक साथ कितने कनेक्शन लगाता चलाने ठीक है
फिर आपका हान एल यूजर ठीक है आपको यूजर
नेम देना है इसे अब एल कैपिटल आता तो मेरे
ख्याल से आपका यूजर नेम लिस्ट दे सकते थे
आप हान प कैपिटल ब ठीक है तो पासवड यानी
पासवर्ड फाइल देनी है आपको हान व यानी
बर्बस मोड ठीक है आपको दिखाएगा मशीन आईपी
पताही क्या है एफटीपी प्रोटोकॉल है आपका
ठीक है यहां प दिखा होगा कहीं पे एटी मतलब
प्रोटोकॉल ठीक है इस पूरे कमांड को हम
क्या करने वाले हैं एज
कॉपी करने वाले हैं और कॉपी करने के बाद य
पर उसको ए इट पेस्ट करने वाले हैं अब हमें
चेंज क्या करना है हमें अपने टारगेट का
आईपी चेंज करना है ट क्या 10
127 10 127 य टट का आईपी हो गया चेंज कर
लिया हमने पासवर्ड फाइल देने वाले उसम
चेंज करने की जरूरत नहीं है नेम जो भी डला
हुआ है इसको हम चेंज करके माइक करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है माइक करते हैं उसको चालू कर
देते हैंटक को
अपने वेट करते हैं टक स्टार्ट होने का अभी
स्टार्ट ही हो रहा हैय
ट करते मिल जाएगा यर मे ल से मुझे इसको
स्मल देना चाहिए
था चलिए चालू कर देते हैं वापस से य
पर क्वेन क्या होने वाला पास पूछेगा उसका
इसके बाद
फिर एने करेगा य पर फाइनल फ्लग लेलेगा
चलिए पास पासवर्ड ही पासवर्ड
है पासवर्ड है भाई चलिए सबमिट करते हैं
इसको कनेक्ट करते हैं
एफटीपी यूजर जरत नहीं
पहले आईपी एड्रेस करते यहां पर कॉपी य पर
पेस्ट ते माइक ठीक है पासवर्ड में हरा
क्या था पासवर्ड ही पासवर्ड है कनेक्ट
हमारा हो चुका है गेट करते हैं
एफटीपी एटीपीटी
एक्सटी ठीक है सीडी करते हैं एफटीपी
फोल्डर आइ ठीक
है इसको सीडी करने के बा देखते हैं यहां
पर फ्यूचर बैकड आरबी यहां पर एक फाइल है
इसको भी सॉरी गेट फ्यू चर बैकअप ड आरबी इस
फाइल को भी यहां पर गेट कर लेते हैं चलिए
फाइल मिल चुकी है एट हमने कर दिया है करते
हैं
ए एक्टी फ्लैग हमें मिल
गया यहां पर कॉपी कर लेते हैं फ्लैग को
काम तो हमारा हो ही गया वो फ्यूचर बैक कोई
मतलब नहीं है ठीक है वो फाइल है तो ठीक है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है एक्सपेंडिंग य नॉलेज
में य कुछ रिसोर्सेस दिए हुए हैं आप इससे
पढ़ सकते हैं ठीक है इतना भी काफी है और
बाकी रिसर्च तो कभी खत्म नहीं होगी आपकी
चलता रहेगा वो तो अगले जो हमारा लेक्चर
आएगा उसमें हम नेटवर्क सर्विसेस का टू
वाला पार्ट करेंगे ठीक है रिवाइस नेटवर्क
स बहुत जरूरी चीज है ठीक है और आपके लिए
समझना जरूरी है लेक्चर आराम से आ रहे हैं
इसलिए आराम से देखिए कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
पर ये जो कांसेप्ट है ना यकीन मानिए सिर्फ
पेन टेस्टिंग में काम नहीं आएंगे आपके हर
जगह काम आएंगे कि आईपी पोर्ट कांसेप्ट आप
कोई भी एप्लीकेशन बनाइए चाहे नेटवर्क बेस
कोई रिवर्स बनाइए कुछ भी बनाइए कोई
प्रोजेक्ट बनाइए पान बनाइए ठीक है जैसे कि
हमारे डिप्लोमा में बनाया गया था ठीक है
और आप में से कोई ऐसा रहा हो डिप्लोमा में
तो आपको पता होगा वो चीज उन सब में आपका
ये नेटवर्क का जो है काम आने वाला है ठीक
है तो इसको अच्छे से एकदम फॉलो करते रहिए
और क्योंकि हम ट्राक में से पढ़ रहे हैं
तो आपको लैब बहुत बढ़िया मिल रहा है तो
प्रैक्टिकल तरीके से समझने के आपको जो है
पूरे रिसोर्सेस मिल रहे हैं और पेड जो
रूम्स है वो भी मैं आपको करा रहा हूं तो
अगर आप पेड परचेस नहीं कर सकते तो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है हम आपके लिए हैं ये वीडियो
आप देखिए आपको वहां समझ में आएगा और ट्राई
इसको कीजिए खुद से ठीक है लोकल लैब सेट अप
कीजिए कैसे भी करिए ट्राई कीजिए बहाना कोई
बनाइए अगर आपके पास ट्रैक में आपको एमबी
नहीं मिल रहा है आप अप सेट अप कीजिए ठीक
है कितना मुश्किल हो मैंने कह दिया वीडियो
में डिफ मतलब य नहीं हो नहीं सकता ठीक है
वेप आपको दिखा रहा हूं पस नहीं आप ट्राई
कीजिए सेट कीजिए ठीक है सीखने को मिलेगा
नुकसान कुछ नहीं होगा ठीक है चलिए य
कंप्लीट करते हैं अगर आपने य रूम साथ
कंप्लीट किया है शेयर की लिन प यहां से
ठीक है हमें टैग करते हुए हमारी कंपनी के
पेज को ठीक है तो आज के लेक्चर में इतना
ही रखते हैं मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लेक्चर में
तब तक के लिए थैंक्स फॉर वाचिंग